we lost a terrific writer recently Brian
Rich oh my gosh which was true terribly
tragic and he had a an illness and we we
all kind of thought he'd beat it and it
came back and it was it was terrible and
then a bunch of us got together to have
um you know sort of a memorial to talk
about Brian rich and
we ended up I mean laughing so hard just
laughing so hard which sounds strange to
some people like it's a memorial you
should be now it was appropriate we were
just talking about how funny he was and
then of course we started talking about
other memories of you know 28 years of
making this very strange these very
strange television shows and um there
was so much affection you could tell
nobody wanted to leave yeah and I
thought this is the thing
I'm like a vampire that hasn't had a
drink of blood right two years I really
miss that so that's why I kicked the
door open I was like I need my I need my
Lord
yeah and you are also nobody has a laser
beam that can take anyone down that's
sharper than Laurie kilmartin there's so
many times where you would just say the
thing in the room actually we have a
contender here yeah
I trained at the Lori kilmartin school I
know
yeah
no that's uh I mean uh it just the
devastating ability to
um to bring me completely back down to
earth
time so much I had so well I'm gonna
figure something out I have to figure
what career is that where we're just we
just have mono meetings
yeah part of it is writing jokes that
you don't like and then you start you
know shredding us for giving you these
shitty jokes I mean I miss that too you
know it's so funny because Stephen
Colbert has a very clear memory of
um years before he was well known he was
working on something with Smigel Robert
Smigel and they were watching the feed
and I was on camera shredding writers in
the way that I do yeah and
um uh in rehearsal in rehearsal and he
saw and he was like wow that's you know
that's that's that's rough and you know
Robert said well Conan has to go out
with material he's the face of it so he
needs to you know and also I'd like to
think that sometimes my deconstruction
of the material was I think funny I hope
oh yeah
it was the whole point yes it was um
often funnier than the funniest thing
but you know that's what angered the
writers
and so but anyway uh what Stephen was
bringing up was we all loved a good joke
and we loved a good sketch but man
something came to rehearsal or something
came into the monologue room that was
completely Regis
um people used to see me lick my lips
yeah because they knew they were in for
that's what really gave you Joy they
knew that they knew they knew that they
were in for 40 minutes and people would
uh of me just going on and on like
picking apart how did this happen how
did this get through uh the safety net
that is supposed to be the head writer
how how did other writers not intervene
basically
how did Jack Ruby get into the
basement you know how was there no one
standing around to say and and that was
that was such a joy because you actually
we were when we were at Comic-Con there
was some
um there was some uh bit we were doing
rehearsing and we had plenty but then
then someone said no no we got something
else and it was R2D2 and he said it was
the last bit of the day it was the last
bit of the day we already had plenty
which is another thing yeah yeah and you
know I want to go upstairs and I want to
play my guitar incessantly and bother
people and um uh and I really I have to
stay at this rehearsal longer and they
said no no it's worth it and then it was
someone had rented an R2D2 robot so R2D2
comes out but he's a he's like a sticky
agent I think I think it was sort of
like yeah yeah
he was like yeah yeah you know you know
I wanted dressing room see I mean I
don't remember what it was
you know it says in my contract he had
totally gone Hollywood and
and it's so funny because
uh Matt O'Brien Sweeney they were
standing sitting in the audience and a
bunch of other people and they said they
saw it come out going beep beep yeah
yeah it's in my contract see beep beep
get up get William Morris Endeavor on
the phone beefy and they said people
said they saw me licking my lips
and then make a shredding began and I
was so happy so happy
oh man I'm gonna figure out a way
that we can I I seriously honestly have
to figure out a way I don't know what it
is but a way where uh clearly
um no one's doing this out of love I
gotta make sure people get paid I gotta
figure out a way that this works I'm
going to figure out a way this works and
and uh but man I would love to do that
because I I yeah I just miss it yes so
much me too me too and get our show
should we do here should we tell you one
of my favorite memory Lori come Martin
memories yeah remember we were at Warner
Brothers
and it's after the show and I'm headed
to the freeway in my car oh God yeah and
I have always seen one Lori kilmartin
which is she's you know delightful she's
upbeat she's super sharp you know all
this stuff and so she's walking along
and I uh I'm slowing down to say
something to her and I see her we're on
an overpass we're on an overpass I'm
walking home we're on a freeway oh she's
walking home and it's a freeway overpass
okay Jessie you're a woman you're not
bubbly on an overpass okay right no
right no no no nor should you be I'm not
I'm just saying it was a complete
misunderstanding but what happened was I
you're just trying to get off the ocean
she's just trying to get off the
overpass you're just trying to get home
and from my perspective oh there's Lori
I'm gonna lower my windows slow down the
car and like say some funny bit you know
like you know
give us a kiss you know that old funny
bit no no just say something funny to
her or yeah or acknowledge that I'm
driving home and there's my friend and
co-worker Martin so what happened but
what I don't understand from her
perspective she's walking along and a
car just suddenly slows down and the
window lowers and all she can see is
what I hope is what looks like a male
figure
um
and
what I saw was you looked over and
before you recognized it was me I saw
the look I saw a look of pure stained
hatred
um reaching for pepper spray yeah yeah
but that look and I immediately
understood so many things I know I'm in
a bubble but I understood so many things
about yeah dude don't slow down and
lower the window at a woman on an
overpass I'm like but it's Laurie I just
wanted to say hi the look you gave me my
penis went up inside my body
and climbed up into my left ventricle
and my heart
where uh it was
Jesus no it detached oh okay it wasn't
it wasn't blank it swam yeah it made its
way up little feet with sneakers on it
um no I was I was just and I was like oh
my God that look you gave me still
horrifies and terrifies me